I told you last week that Donald Trump
personally lawyered up in the Russia
investigation and that Mark Casa wits is
the lawyer who has worked with Trump
before and also represents a Russian
bank no joke who will be representing
Donald Trump personally and he's
previously defended Trump in business
matters
public relations disputes in the Trump
University stuff in one of trumps
divorces but Kazu 'its has no experience
dealing with the Justice Department
investigations of this magnitude or
congressional investigations so there's
a sort of obvious question here why hire
Casa wits for something with which he
has no experience we are getting the
answer to that question and it is coming
from Michael Isikoff now reporting that
there were four major law firms
prestigious law firms in the country
that were asked to represent Donald
Trump in the Russia investigations and
they all refused
according to five different sources with
knowledge of the matter the sources say
that this was in part because those
lawyers believed Donald Trump wouldn't
listen to their advice that is
absolutely ridiculous Pat that's not the
Trump we know the Trump we know always
takes advice from experts in their field
doesn't know I'm sure yeah I mean this
is pretty remarkable too because you'd
think that some of the top law firms in
the country would jump at the
opportunity to represent the prize
exactly but apparently they must think
that he has no case here because even if
they thought it was an uphill battle
they may still go along with it think
about the scenario right Michael Cohen
Trump's other Trump's organizational
lawyer goes to the White House tells
Trump you need to personally lawyer up
since we've got this Justice Department
investigation multiple congressional
committees are investigating possible
ties to Russia so Trump says fine I'm
going to find an experienced lawyer the
first four law firms that he speaks to
say no thanks and Trump ends up with
Mark Kazu it's who knows Trump has no
experience in this field and has
represented a Russian bank and there are
other reasons I believe beyond Trump
won't listen one lawyer said that it
would kill recruitment for their firm
and kill the reputation of it saying do
I want to be associated with this
president and his policies one of the
attorneys who turned down
trumpet Ted Olson Ted Olson recall was
the Solicitor General under president
george w bush and one of the major
voices in favor of the fight for gay
marriage not willing to represent trump
one of the attorneys said that another
reason they wouldn't represent trump is
that some of their clients financial
institutions have already been
subpoenaed with regard to money
laundering as part of the trump russia
investigation that's like a footnote in
this story and it is also major which is
that there are financial institutions
major ones whose records are being
subpoenaed in the russian investigation
that is something maybe we'll hear more
about in the future it sounds like a hot
potato that they don't want to hold on
to for too long yeah i mean i think just
the fact that donald trump is luring up
doesn't really tell us too much because
there are serious charges that could
potentially be brought against them if
you're if you're innocent you want a
lawyer but the fact that no lawyers are
really willing to jump on board and are
hesitant to do so that's pretty telling
can you imagine being Trump's lawyer and
having to deal with the tweets like how
on earth do you handle that and there
were also concerns that trump wouldn't
pay the attorney as we know Donald Trump
has a long history of not paying people
who perform services for them this is
almost an alternate universe law firms
don't want to represent the President of
the United States something that is pat
pointed out that would be a great client
for a lot of law firms because they feel
that the president number one wouldn't
listen to their advice and number two
might never pay them for their services
and two you're tweeting point I mean
imagine if these lawyers spend months
developing a case and then Trump
undermines it with one tweet like he did
with the travel ban I don't blame them
for not wanting to represent Trump on
this it actually makes a lot of sense to
me on the bonus show today housing a
prisoner in California now costs more
than a year at Harvard including room
board books a laptop and many nights of
drinking out at Boston and Cambridge
bars that is how expensive it is to
house a prisoner in California WikiLeaks
is offering $10,000 to get an intercept
reporter fired and there are some people
and I will tell you who those people are
accusing Donald Trump of violating the
First Amendment by blocking people on
Twitter is there any
to that we will talk about it on the
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership sign up today
I voted 17 is the coupon code available
to you